speaking of water Southern Nevada Water
Authority the sponsors of this segment
is back with the summer water
restrictions here's how they're helping
you save money in our community save
water
[Music]
my name is Corey Enos and I am with the
Southern Nevada Water Authority and I'm
here to talk to you about mandatory
summer watering restrictions as the
calendar goes from May to August it's
time for all of us to adhere to our
summer water restrictions it's one of
the easiest and most impactful ways for
us to save water that means no watering
between the hours of 11 A.M and 7 P.M
when the temperature is at its hottest
and that water is going to be lost to
evaporation absolutely no watering on
Sundays just because you can water six
days a week now doesn't mean you have to
you should ramp up and as the
temperatures begin to get hotter begin
to increase the amount of days that you
water let's talk about the best ways or
methods of Watering your grass and
plants this season
for grass which is watered by sprinklers
or spray irrigation believe it or not
the grass only needs 12 minutes per day
that's three times a day about four
minutes a piece a spaced one hour report
apart and drip irrigation your trees and
plants need a lot less water possibly
two to three times a week all summer
last summer I never increased my
watering past three days a week with my
uh with my landscape adhering to
mandatory watery restrictions is not
only a way to save yourself and our
community water but it's also a way to
save you money you can avoid costly
Water waste fine checking your
irrigation to make sure it's functioning
properly and water is not flowing off of
your property can save you water waste
fines they can range from eighty dollars
at the beginning all the way up to three
four five thousand dollars so it's
important to save our community water
and save your pocketbook money as well
making sure that your watering is not
occur occurring there in the hours of 11
A.M to 7 P.M after each mowing at your
property check your sprinklers to make
sure nothing is malfunctioning make sure
your sprinkler heads are the appropriate
size and shape for your landscaping and
none of that water is leaving your
property and it's doing what it's
supposed to be doing Watering your
landscape keeping your Landscaping
functioning properly making sure none of
that water is leaving your property and
that it's getting where it needs to be
on your Landscaping will save you money
and will save our community water
something that a lot of people don't
think of as a way to save water or smart
irrigation controllers if you go to
snwa.com we have a rebate for installing
a smart irrigation controller it will do
a lot of the work for you it'll sense
moisture in the air it'll shut off if
it's a rainy day smart irrigation
controllers can connect to your phone
allowing you the ability to control your
irrigation system even when you're not
at home go to snwa.com to find tips on
watering when new water how often you
should water and ways to water just
because you can water six days a week
doesn't mean you should
thank you Southern Nevada Water
Authority for sponsoring that segment
for more information call
702-258 save or head to
snwa.com we'll be right back